[Music]
foreign
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today is an epic day I interviewed
somebody that I've been watching for so
long I have been hoping to get on the
show for so long and I really think this
is going to register with the people
watching because these spiritual
esoteric
outer space extraterrestrial like
episodes do well and this is all that in
a bag of chips it's with Billy Carson he
founded the television station Forbidden
Knowledge TV he has a book called
compendium of The Emerald Tablets that's
a bestseller for four years I think he
said now since the age of seven and at
seven he started researching Aerospace
at seven
so this guy has spent his whole life
diving into research reading he said
over a thousand books the amount of
information that you're going to get in
this episode is kind of overwhelming
Billy was phenomenal we talked about
Egypt we talked about the Anunnaki we
talked about extraterrestrials DNA
Bloodlines nefarious energies and forces
on this planet what our body is made up
of and how it works and the general
nature of this this reality and my
favorite question which is how do we
play this game the very best we can so
that we're as happy as possible so so
much of this episode I hope you love it
as much as I do please hit subscribe
please hit the bell for notifications
when you're ready to hear when we have
episodes come out and how about some fun
in the messages what were your favorite
topics I'd love to hear about it anyway
enjoy the episode
how are you I'm fantastic nice to meet
you yeah you too um what do you think of
our friend PJ
oh he's a great guy great great man I
met him at a Dr almond Foundation event
we're sitting at the same table and we
both had brain injuries
um and obviously Dr Alma was our doctor
so it was a great event and that's how I
met him yeah oh you had a brain injury
too yeah yeah I was ejected from a car I
was ejected from a car through the front
windshield over the car that we hit uh I
didn't have a seat belt on obviously I
was I was 20 years old I believe and
um and like a rocket and tore this whole
eyelid off so all this is like
reconstructed here and uh wow it created
a hole in the back of my brain and it
messed up my navigation Center so I
would get for decades I'd get lost in my
own house lost in neighborhoods
lost at the airport and it was a real
pain but a year ago Dr almond I started
working with him and my brain has been
completely reconfigured and the hole is
gone and those two giant dimples were my
navigation
uh perfectly normal now they filled in
huh that's a miracle I mean yeah you
just uh got a computer upgrade yeah
exactly
yeah it's great great feeling to know
where you're going
I would think that'd probably be pretty
scary for a while
yeah you kind of get used it's very
frustrating you know the airport down
here where I live in Fort Lauderdale
they knew my voice you know and when I
call them say hey I can't find my car
they knew they knew who I was right when
I would answer the phone when I would
call them and they would pick up and say
hey this is Billy you know they knew me
that so what they did was they installed
this new system there because I was
traveling so many times a week where
anybody who pulls head in they can track
where you park because your driver's
license I mean your license plate they
have a special camera system now I think
it was primarily because of how many
phone calls I made to them
everyone now knows and they can thank
you for that yeah yeah exactly well
thank you for doing this
um I've been watching your stuff and
listening for so long and fascinated by
ancient history and civilizations and
the nature of reality and what are we
and so it was very overwhelming for me
to think where do I start with you
because I know we don't have all day and
so I don't know how it'll end up going
exactly but I thought I would kind of
break this down is it I've never kind of
done an interview quite in this
structure but I thought I'd come I had
four questions like four primary
questions and I thought we could just
sort of go off on those because there
were so many things that fit Within
These Concepts and ideas and so I
thought I'll just how about we just
answer at least whatever four burning
questions I have about life and so I'm
gonna start with the one that actually
probably led me down this path
so deeply it wasn't like it started it
but it was the thing that really like
catapulted me into
deep curiosity and YouTube hours and
hours and hours on YouTube and that's
the question
what is God
not who that's a deep one what is God I
love it yeah okay so you want to start
now yeah yeah okay all right beautiful
so
the question you ask is what is God and
that's a really really deep question a
lot of people struggle with that
question it's like the question we all
ask ourselves who are we where are we
from what is God who is God why me what
was my mission here
and I think the more I analyze that
question myself the more I found it
wasn't something on the outside
the deeper I got into looking into
researching uh spirituality and the
science is that back spirituality which
some of that I actually learned believe
it or not at MIT I began to realize that
it's really a journey to Inner Space and
so when you start looking at the micro
you discover what's on the macro and so
in quantum physics and subatomic physics
you want to find out when you look at
the smallest scale of things it gives
you almost an identical mirror as to
what's going on on the larger scale
so I began to realize that God
is us and we're God and that God is on a
data collection Mission and the whole
premise of this third dimensional uh
realm and human beings operating in this
realm and potential other alien beings
and everything else throughout the
entire universe are all doing one thing
very simple collecting information and
sending it back to the source so I think
that when you ask that question it's
such a broad question but to summarize
it it's like this the human brain is
encased in darkness it can't see smell
taste here it knows nothing that's going
on in the outside but it does have
friends it has a sensory perception so
you can touch something you can smell
you can hear but it says your sentence
go out and and bring me back some
information so the friends go out and
they touch and they smell and they taste
and they hear and they see and they
bring that data back to the brain and
then the brain takes that data and the
friends don't know what they have they
only have the information they gotta
bring it back to the brain the brain
then sorts it all out and projects a
hologram as to what's potentially going
on outside of itself and we navigate
through that hologram based on a
projection from data collected by our
sensory perception
so when I saw that when I was able to
extrapolate that I then took it to the
big to the macro and I said okay so the
universe is a mind God is part of this
universal mind this Universal
Consciousness and it's only one
Consciousness and it has uh it has
really separated itself into Googles of
entities because Google's a number
Google's a number and then separating
yourself yeah Google's an actual number
yeah it's not a search engine
so that what they're trying to say is
we've got so many searches you know
because they've named their search
engine after our number and so it
separated itself into Googles of
entities so that they can uh find out
what it's like to live in the third
Dimensions Dimension subjectively as me
you a blade of grass even a rock you
know a tree and so all of these living
things that exist throughout the entire
Third Dimension are all doing one thing
they are transmitting back to Source all
the information of what it's like to be
a blade of grass what it's like to be
Billy Carson what it's like to be Danica
Patrick and so the universal
Consciousness is actually taking this
information and it's actually collecting
this data to analyze what is it like to
operate through this Grand experiment of
this third dimension it's a learning
process and we're all a part of that and
so God has literally imbued every atom
in the entire universe with this Divine
Consciousness and we know now through
every single individual atom it has
electrons orbiting it and those
electrons can make conscious decisions
based on observation we know this
because of the doubles to the experiment
in quantum physics so because every atom
is conscious that means that everything
made of atoms is conscious so this whole
universe is one entity experiencing
itself subjectively as Ghouls and
Googles of entities and things that
exist and things that we think are
inanimate like even in this microphone
for example is made of conscious atoms
so this microphone is not just an
inanimate man-made object we didn't make
this microphone what man did was stack
conscious atoms together like Legos and
then because of the format we stacked
them in it allows us to utilize this as
a microphone and so it's all about
understanding that we are God and God is
us it's in everything and we're in
everything and separation separation is
an illusion division is an illusion
distance is even an illusion everything
is actually all one we've been given
this Grand experiment through the third
dimension uh to experience the illusion
of these things but in reality it's all
about sending information back to source
and it starts with us we all are God
Walking In the Flesh there's only one
Consciousness if you can imagine a radio
station in your neighborhood it's
transmitting out all these frequencies
right 99.1 99.2 99.3 so forth and so on
and so what it's doing that one central
location sending out multiple
frequencies right waves of light and
then you have a receiver and that
receivers you tune it to pick up point
one point two point three point four
and so that's what's happening I'm 99.1
0.2 0.3.4 my avatar body has been
designed to encapsulate Point number
frequency of the one Consciousness
that's already being transmitted from
One Source it gives me the illusion with
you that we're two separate beings but
in reality our spiritual energy is
coming from One Source you just have
picked up a slightly different frequency
of the source than I did as well so I'm
attuned to point one you were tuned to
point two and so forth and so on and
that's how it actually works so it's a
frequency
it's a frequency God is a frequency it's
our job to tune in God is not a man you
hear people say reference God is him he
they have this illusion that there's
this Sky daddy with a magic wand
floating around granting wishes that
just really in my research isn't the
case it's more of a frequency a Divine
frequency that is imbued in every living
thing in the entire universe
so where did religion come along
that's a great question so in ancient
times people were more into spirituality
and then they just well when we got to
one of the highest Advanced
civilizations which started out in Sumer
and then migrated over into the land of
kamet before it became Egyptian assumer
Samaria yes it is Samaria yes and when
would that have been but a tablet stayed
back about six to eight thousand years
but those tablets we discovered were
recopied from even older tablets which
going back probably about a hundred to
two hundred thousand years prior we're
talking about a deep deep Antiquity of
super ancient culture even in the
Emerald Tablets when they relocated home
base to the land of kamet and the animal
tablets are 36 000 year old texts they
rebuild the land of Kim uh out of the
mud which because there was a great
flood so we're talking about ancient
knowledge they said they rebuilt Camp
they didn't build it for the first time
they said they were going to bring it
back up to a high level of civilization
so it was already high before the flood
we're talking about tens of thousands of
years ago and so they begin to create
these Mystery Schools uh at this dawn of
this new era 36 000 years ago the
gentleman who started this his name was
Thoth t-h-o-t-h and he's known as a
wisdom keeper he's known all over the
entire world and every continent I've
been to there's a depiction of him there
even in the Outback of Australia they've
got them etched into a Petro Griffin in
the Rock okay and since it's wow
the long big nose yes exactly that
that's him he's he doesn't really have a
bird head but he's depicted as such
because the the Ibis bird depicts
bringing Darkness to light because the
beak is so long it goes deeper down into
the mud to bring sustenance up
symbolic symbolic right symbology that's
exactly what it is but he ruled over the
land of chemet for 14 or 16 000 years
roughly thereabout according to the
ancient Egyptians and then he left there
and went to mesoamerica and kicked
started the teotiwakan civilization it
in Mexico City you have teotubicon you
have all down throughout um Tulum and
all the way down to Chichen Itza that
was all his master architectural plan
until tiwicon is part of his African
name which is also known as tahuti and
tiricon in Mexico really means uh the
city of tahuti that he built out there
so he left there and that's why the
pyramid complex here mirrors the one at
Giza in Africa and Kem when you refer to
Kim is where he went next that's Egypt
that's Egypt yeah so Kim after uh Kim
fell after a golden age they fell and
when it uh came back you know they the
dogons were overthrown there and they
would move that to Mali Africa and a new
group came in uh and that was probably
closer to one of the first dynastic
periods that started and that was still
a long long time ago but over time the
name Egypt which came out of Greece took
hold and that's the name we call it
today but the original name of the land
is chemist and so these these Mystery
Schools started and so these Mystery
Schools were to teach the spirituality
to Adept initiates and to pass it down
uh through verbal teachings and then
when some of these super Masters began
to pass away or leave or disappear
whatever you want to call it
some of these pyramid priests and Temple
priests realized the power that this
knowledge had and begin to alter and
remix it they understood the psychology
and the Neuroscience behind this and how
it could control masses of people so
they started to twist the the scripture
and twist the words
um and kind of utilize it for Darkness
instead of light and then we're able to
then put people into a box and put real
controls on them and dominate them and
secure them bringing them food bringing
them sacrifices bringing them money the
sacrifices were not for God the
sacrifices were so they can eat
they weren't going to go hunting yeah
you know what I mean a lamb sure yeah
exactly if you go to Egypt you go to all
these temples you'll find the storehouse
where all the sacrifices would be put in
salted and stored and hung and dried so
that these people can have food to eat
because they weren't going to go hunting
for anything they weren't going to grow
any crops so it was all the big scam so
religion started with Toth or was that
just because he started putting things
down on a tablet is there so this was
this was sort of the start of it
yeah so they they took his teachings his
spiritual teachings he's all about
seeking a light evading the darkness
understanding how to raise and be born
again through conscious thought the
first baptism that was taught is in the
animal tablets he talks about being
baptized via elevated Consciousness
being able to rise up to another level
and look back to see where you were
before and you'll be born again many
times in one lifetime if you continue to
ascend it had nothing to do with
splashing water and dumping your head in
the pool and all this other kind of
stuff uh that was also another Twist of
the of the information if you look at
the animal tablet so I wrote this book
called compendium of the animal tablets
which has been a bestseller worldwide
for four years it's now I've been
currently number one actually number one
out of three million books in ancient
civilizations uh in that book I put the
New Testament where Jesus is speaking
and I put both the atlanteans words from
The Emerald Tablets side by side and you
see that Jesus is literally mimicking
what he learned from the ancient mystery
schools which he learned directly from
the Egyptian mysteries from both the
atlanteans teachings so he's not saying
anything new in the New Testament all
those words that were spoken by him were
information that he was taught because
the real text is 36
000 years old and of course we know the
Bible was written between 180 to 900 a
day long after the people were long gone
so it's just a mimicking of ancient
texts and people began to take spiritual
Concepts and a lot of different
religions cropped out of his spiritual
writings that he wrote in those animal
tablets
so have you seen the the documentary
movie called zeitgeist
yes were they basic it was fascinating
the beginning is all about basically
Jesus and the 12 apostles and dying and
reborn three days later and the timing
and everything and and they overlay it
into more and more and more ancient
times and how it's the same story over
and over again so is that the is that an
archetypical archetypal thing or is that
um the same Consciousness coming back
over and over again and doing the same
thing is that someone learning from the
past why would that happen
yeah so the story kept getting Rewritten
the story did happen originally
thousands of years before Jesus was even
born and then the story kept getting
copied over and over and over the true
story of Jesus has really never
truthfully fully been read this the the
Sinai Bible is probably closest to the
truth because the Sinai Bible was
written before the King James Bible and
some of the other canonized books and
there's about 14 000 differences between
the two and one of the biggest
discrepancies is Jesus was never
crucified matter of fact
Harvard has a copy of the book of
Jesus's wife in its Seminary Library
what so most likely he got married had
kids and the Merovingian bloodline most
likely is still walking the planet till
this very very day and so I think that
those stories of the ancient situ uh you
know the ancient cultures having that
same story over and over again was just
it being copied again from culture to
culture and being re-read and the names
being suddenly changed but it happened
originally uh thousands of years prior
with horse
so did the actual actions happen again
or it's just the story being Rewritten
over and over again just the story being
Rewritten over and over again with
different names uh to the same exact
tale yeah just like if you read the Epic
of Gilgamesh you discover that's the
true story of Noah's Ark in the Bible
they copied it from the Epic of
Gilgamesh it's not two separate stories
it's the same exact story being
Rewritten
so who was Jesus then what is the story
I believe that Jesus his real name is
Yeshua first of all he was a real person
that did exist I've been to the house
where he grew up uh in Egypt because if
you remember in the Bible Jesus
disappears from the Bible at the age of
12. disappears you don't see him again
till he's 32. he's gone where does he go
the gospel of the Holy twelve which was
left out of the Bible has the answer he
goes to Egypt I've been there if you go
to Coptic Cairo you can go to the house
where Jesus and his mother lived in
there in in that area and it's become
they turned it into like a crypt now so
you can go there you can you know see
where the bed he slept in and everything
is still there and um he was learning
the Egyptian Mysteries
from there he went all the way up into
Tibet to learn Reiki healing and Qigong
and that's been confirmed by the Dalai
Lama and then he left from there and
went down into India to learn the Mystic
Arts teaching reincarnation all the way
back to Egypt and then the Bible picks
up I call my son out of Egypt and then
you see him appear on the back of a
donkey in Jerusalem at the age of 32.
and that's where the Bible text picks
him back up is coming back in but he was
a very spiritual being he was a virgin
birth
and what's interesting is in the
Apocrypha text the text that was kept
out of the Bible you discover his
grandmother Mary's mother was also a
virgin birth
and if you look at the Sumerian Tablets
you discover that these virgin births
were not unusual they were experimenting
in these types of in vitro fertilization
techniques where they would take an egg
and put it in the womb and take it the
term not their egg another uh woman's
egg
um and they have this whole section in
Egypt called uh the hathor's temple at
dundera where they have these birthing
centers where they were doing yes I've
been there yeah the front the when you
walk into dundera the first temple on
the right
um inside the main Temple and then
there's isis's Temple behind that yes
that's it absolutely yeah well they get
that right at least they said that that
was the birthing Temple they got that
right yeah I think he's half human half
Atlantean that's my personal opinion so
if they were placing an egg inside of a
woman it wasn't hers right correct so he
was a virgin so what does his
grandmother was also a virgin birth they
were planted on this timeline for a
specific reason by the people who
control from behind the scenes which
were these they call themselves The
ordainers of Destiny in the Sumerian
Tablets they control they believe they
had the right to control Destinies on
this planet and they would they would
use this Crystal tablet to see potential
outcomes and Futures that they wanted
and they would then pick the one they
wanted to coalesce into one real outcome
and they would go behind go go ahead
putting action behind that to make that
reality come true for them
Masters at manifesting so was this
Bloodlines then were they were they
playing with Bloodlines and the inherent
skills that these Bloodlines or these
inherent genetic
um advantages that they had was that
what they were working with to create
a superhuman do exactly right they had
prior to the flood
the Annunaki who are also the atlanteans
that's the same people the atlantine is
the civilization Anunnaki means those
who came from Heaven to Earth so it's
like if we travel to Mars we wouldn't
say I wouldn't say I'm Billy Carson from
Boca Raton Florida I would say I'm an
Earthling right so Annunaki is that
generalized term Atlantean is the type
of civilization they created so and so
um basically what you find is that
before the flood they didn't even
interact with the hominids that were on
this planet they didn't interact with us
our cousins were here not Homo sapiens
sapiens but a different version of us
was already here
then they started tinkering because they
wanted to create a slave race of people
and then after the flood they decided to
utilize this new Tinker genetically
modified version of a homo sapien sapien
uh and they would they would create
leaders of these areas like for example
a pharaoh would be and the initial
pharaohs would be a direct bloodline of
one of these Anunnaki people in other
words it would be half human and half
Anunnaki where the term demigod comes
from in Greek and Rome and all of that
um and so they were baked that liaison
that bloodline liaison between them and
the people
As Time continued to go by and and
cultures and the way that the economics
and the civilizations and the kingship
and everything changed they began to
then for whatever reason hand-picked
specific people to do specific things
and they would then create these
genetically modified or bloodline people
Yeshua was one of them
um who I believe he was half human and
half Annunaki that's just my personal
opinion I have not read that anywhere
but that's based on what I've researched
yeah and what I know from studying
ancient cultures I believe that he was
not one he well he himself said he's not
of this world which means he's an alien
okay that's the definition it's true
it's a definition uh and so I believe
that he was a chosen one for whatever
the full mission was and I think the
real mission was to bring a certain
level of Christ to Consciousness which
existed before Jesus Christ that
terminology ever came to be Christ's
Consciousness is ancient it's super
ancient and it's a certain level of
Consciousness that a person can get to
this level where they're all knowing all
loving they're they're the epitome of
service to others and unconditional love
for for one another uh you know a real
true ascended being and Jesus never said
he was going to return He said the
Christ would return and he's talking
about the Consciousness coming back to
this planet and raising everyone up to a
higher level and bringing back a new
golden age that's a level of
Consciousness where you have this
crystallized Consciousness where
everything you think of is about how can
I become a problem solver I'm not a
victim how can I help someone how can I
love this person better how can I solve
problems before they happen because a
genius will solve problems before they
happen so these people were high level
thinkers they'll think into the future
and think of what all the outcomes can
be and then create Solutions before they
even need them that kind of level of
thinking uh how to heal people not no
suppression of medical technology and
information and stuff like that creating
a true super Christ civilization it
definitely looks like in ancient times
um Akhenaten and Nefertiti yeah there's
no chance that they're they're like
human like we would think they had a
very androgynous odd bodies Long Heads
um Extended skulls like they did they
really exist or are they okay I always
wondered that about some of the ancient
history of Egypt and Osiris and Isis and
were they sort of energetic
representations were they are they
archetypal to describe a story and a
pattern or a Consciousness or an energy
or were these really people yeah they
were real people they actually did live
and exist and walk amongst men
they said that they would walk amongst
men but unlike men which means that they
were something a little different
and uh when you look at the stories
about them you realize that they were
real they have found the bust of
Nefertiti they found this uh statue of
her full body which existed the head's
missing but the body's there so you can
see the full body was it like was it an
akhenaten's shaped body where the hips
she had a lot of fish she had a lot of
curves
so to knock it up yeah I know it was
weird the weird bodies and uh Akhenaten
he really existed because he literally
was ousted so Aqua not in his King Tut's
father Queen taiye and I'm gonna have to
third was uh King Tut's grandfather and
grandmother Akhenaten he got in big
trouble because when you go to Egypt if
you if you ever notice all those chipped
away Gods all those people are chipped
away all their faces that was under the
order initially who started that
akhanatan so akanatan decided I'm going
to become a monotheistic uh ruler and
not you know not the kind of believes in
multiple gods and so and what got into
him was almond Raw who's also felt's
brother his brother his name is Marduk
in the Bible in the Jewish Torah but in
Egypt his name is uh Aman ra he's the
one who said whenever you give thanks
you say Amen to me you give thanks to me
this is why people say amen they're not
saying Amen to the creator of the
universe they're actually saying Amen to
this guy who says a brutal killing ruler
an evil dude who was so jealous he said
scratched that from my vocab listen he
said there'll be no other God but me
that was the terminology that made it
into the actual biblical text I'm a
jealous guard that made it into the
biblical text why would the creative
Universe be jealous why would the
creative Universe demand that other gods
which means there are other gods I'm
surprised they haven't left it in there
you know exist and so this was almond
raw talking and you can look him up on
the Jewish American library and all that
stuff his name is all over the place
he's all in there interacting and
talking and creating all kinds of issues
and problems and he told akkenaten that
you worship me and you get everyone to
worship me and deface all the other gods
so I cannot and started ordering and
decreeing that all these things be
chipped away everywhere you go chipped
away the faces chip away the ears the
Romans when I went yeah no no no no I
could not go into the Super ancient
history you find it akinaten that's why
he was kicked out of Egypt he was kicked
out of Egypt and when he left Egypt he
went to the king to the Great Pyramid
and he went to that stone box area
inside the king chamber and took the Ark
of the Covenant with him see Akhenaten
is Moses
that's the Moses story he takes that
with him he flees with all his new
followers there were no slaves in Egypt
I'm gonna say this again there were no
slaves in Egypt working on pyramids
their people had their home slaves but
there were nobody building pyramids we
know this for a fact because we have all
the work records we discovered all the
broken legs broken arm records we have
all the payroll records all of them yes
it's all done we have oh it's all in the
museum now so we have all the
information that show of these people
were paid they had insurance they had
coverage and all this we know for a fact
that these people were not slaves the
people that were this this Exodus that
left out of Egypt they were the people
who converted from believing in multiple
gods to believing in the one God
religion monotheism following Akhenaten
and he fled with all these people out of
Egypt with the Ark of the Covenant and
that's why
the powers that be sent an army after
they're like you took the source of our
power with you we got to have that and
they fled after him he never crossed the
Red Sea when you that's a mistranslation
in the Bible he crossed the Sea of reeds
which is a closer much smaller sea and
when you do their geological rewind
which we have the computer model
simulate now around that same time frame
that this happened there was a massive
earthquake and a tsunami estimated to be
in that region which means it would have
sucked all the water out and would have
come crashing back
so you see how stories get remixed
what's happened there was a natural
disaster and perfect timing
um but they they didn't end up in the
desert with the Ark of the Covenant
which is well noted and documented in
biblical text all right so what was the
ark of the covenant a super Advanced
technological machine it was
multi-purposeful we know this because of
the way that it's designed and what it
reads you know what it says what it was
capable of doing it's a weapon but it
also has a capability of being a power
source so it does multiple things and to
handle it you have to have lead okay you
had to have these special kind of boots
on because it was a capacitor and some
scientists at several universities
experimented with recreating The Arc
using the instructions that are in the
Bible and it was so powerful they had to
shut it down what yeah this is anybody
can Google this this is like it was
mainstream news about maybe 15 years ago
they've done this already they've
reproduced it and it actually turned on
what did the cherubs do what did the
Angels the cherubs do what
electricity yes exactly a big spark when
you look up the video on YouTube You'll
see a big spark jumping across an arc
that's the arc that's why they call it
the arc it's the arc which is the elect
you know the electromagnetic Arc as
jumps from one cherubim to the next
I've also heard that incense and and the
smoke from it was used to be able to see
the energy
be able to see like the electricity and
the energy working that it was part of
its the a way to and that's kind of
where some of the
incense became ceremonial it's like when
you see a laser show they have to put
that mist out there yeah it's like light
the air yes exactly same same exact
thing that's exactly what they did
more than one Arc too there wasn't
there's more than one ARP that is
correct there's more than one Arc there
was more than one Arc
um they've all been taken now so nobody
knows where they are the last one that
we knew of was in Ethiopia an Ethiopian
church and a guy discovered it there
about seven or eight years ago and he
went public with it and then within a
year it was stolen from there because
there was no military no no police no
security just some Temple and uh Church
priests you know guarding it so they
took it very easily and that was the
last one known him that was publicly
available the rest are probably in some
type of a military bunker I think Graham
Hancock did a pretty deep dive on the
arc and they the anybody that interacted
with the ark would essentially not want
the job because they would die yeah they
would die they would get what looked
like radiation sickness their eyes would
start bleeding their nose to start
bleeding their nails would fall off
their skin would boil their hair would
fall out that sounds like radiation
sickness so what did they use it for in
ancient times where it was productive
the Great Pyramid itself is a power
generator that's one of the purposes
just that's just one it was a
multi-functional stone computer also but
just for the purposes of this
it was built on top of an aquifer and
the now used to run very close to the
pyramids on Giza now it's way mannered
way way all the temples all the temples
have their ramps and you can see that it
doesn't look like normal steps like the
water was right up to like all the
temples right exactly right up to them
and the water running underneath the
Great Pyramid would run underneath in
that aquifer and that moving water would
then run right underneath the uh solid
Granite magnetized Granite uh that was
their Crystal Granite now when you have
running water against magnetized Crystal
Granite which is the base there it
creates physiostatic electricity those
ions would get pushed up into the grand
gallery and they had used to have
resonating rods in the slots going up
the grand Gallery when it got to the
king's chamber some other type of you
know Fusion would happen and it would
then send the energy up through the Apex
and the Apex which is now missing would
then transmitted out wirelessly to the
Obelisk which then collect this ambient
electricity and if you had a Jed you can
pick up this ambient wireless
electricity you can see the jet
connected to light bulbs and so forth
like a narrow the one the jet has the
three or four bars on it exactly and so
Nick letes to copy that same Energy
power technique with the warden Cliff
Tower and so what at when the water
shifted away began to meander away and I
think it really happened after the last
pyramid War it broke the stone computer
it broke the stone uh power generator
and so what they realized was we can
take this Arc and we could put it in
this they made this makeshift Granite
box which is not a sarcophagus because I
can't even fit in I'm six foot four
I said just fine I was totally fine my
my toning inside of the Box felt sounded
great nice but it's definitely not big
enough it's been seen the real ones
they're giant they're massive I had to
bend my knees so I knew it wasn't a
sarcophagus but it's the same exact I
measured it it's the same exact
dimensions as what the Ark of the
Covenant identical Dimensions which
means it fit right in that box and so if
you don't have the water you need
something else to Arc the power perfect
location to put it in the king's chamber
to send the energy through the Apex so
they can keep the wireless wireless
energy going energy yeah so when
Akhenaten took that he took the power
source for Egypt send you right back in
time if you don't have power and also no
one would want that right now because
institutions would lose billions of
dollars because you would be allowing
free energy free energy puts everyone on
the equal playing field you know no more
third world country if you got energy
and water everybody's equal and they
don't want that they want to keep the
boot on the necks of the people and
control and hoard the power in one
region so they can dominate the rest of
the planet what do you believe the
temples were used for temples had a
couple of different purposes one they're
built on top of these uh extreme
magnetic fields and so in some way they
would harness those magnetic fields for
some type of energy purposes in some way
they were utilizing this energy for like
the Fountain of Youth that utilize it to
for for anti-aging techniques and
anti-aging methods also there's a couple
of temples that people sick people will
be allowed to go into right it would
walk between these two magnetized
Granite plates and it would heal them
for the Anunnaki Atlantean people or the
Pharaohs it was anti-aging they've done
experiments inside of some of these
temples and some of these similar
magnetic fields where plants grow twice
as fast and are more abundant uh and so
you know they were they were built plus
also the design of them had ancient
secrets and Mysteries encoded into the
actual construction technique right that
was left behind for people to read
people who knew the brick masons and so
forth they get information from these
structures and buildings in the pattern
of the building of the temple like how
the rooms were organized how you'd walk
through it yeah
right exactly I ended up getting a
feeling when I was there that
um
it felt like where they used to practice
magic what we would call Magic now they
used to it felt like something somewhere
they used to practice those things do
everything from change the weather to
heal people see they understood
something so the English language which
is now dominated the entire planet
that's not an accident the English the
English language is the weakest language
and what I mean by that
words have power
words can literally affect and change
the ether of space-time itself
and the further back you go in time the
closer you get to the language of Light
which is what the ancient kemetic people
in Egyptians would speak back in ancient
times those words had supreme power over
over reality itself
and um and so you know just speaking
certain ways and saying certain things
can control different outcomes because
we know cymatic frequencies which are
created by our vocal cords they emanate
out of you we think they're just words
but they're actually codes that the
Universe picks up programming codes and
in the universe then enacts those codes
that's how a lot of things happen and so
it's um it's a way of you know creating
different realities since the power of
the voice and the power of speaking and
so you know coming into English which is
now dominant dominated the whole planet
we have one of the weakest forces that
we can speak it's easy to understand
it's easy to pick up but it has the
least power over the space-time energy
I want to talk about DNA but I feel like
I want to talk about
where we came from Anunnaki
what we are made of like what makes us
up like what makes us humans so going
back then it's really generally like
what isn't the extraterrestrials role in
the civilization
so where did it begin from your
knowledge well if you look at these
ancient Sumerian Tablets a special
tablet and there's two actually real
good ones the Epic of atrajasis and the
enuma Elish and the Seven Tablets of
Creation those are two separate writings
that are so profound
because they talk about not only our
solar system but the actual creation of
our solar system they talk about the
creation of Earth itself
that information from the inum English
got copied into the modern day bible but
only a small amount of it the full story
is in the inum English you discover that
a very long time ago there was another
planet named Tiamat this planet was
actually the fourth planet Mars was a
habitable Moon of that planet this
planet was four to six times larger than
Earth a water bearing Planet would land
in life and supposedly it's when the sun
reflected off of it it was so beautiful
it would rival the sun's Glory that's
how beautiful this planet was
now in this process of the formation of
our solar system there were a lot of
different rogue planets uh and and moons
that were out of sorts and uh on this
one orbit this one collided with Tiamat
and broke it into pieces
now a giant piece swung away and
re-coalesced with all the water organic
life it used to have living people on it
re-coalesced and move them to the third
position and tugged along with it lamu
which is the moon and became the earth
and the rest of it broke up into giant
chunks and became the asteroid belt and
then it slung Mars into this weird
elliptical orbit around the Sun and
computer models by NASA and the European
Space Agency confirmed this that Mars
used to orbit another planet that's now
missing and which is why it has such a
weird orbit
and when you look at Mars one side is
charred the other side is smooth
and which is crazy so it means that the
side that's charged the side that took
the brunt of the hit from the exploding
pieces of Tiamat and also Mars equator
is not perfectly straight it's been
shifted about 45 degrees which means the
mass that hit it tugged on the crust and
shifted it about 45 degrees so that's
the evidence that's the circumstantial
evidence we have of this planet uh the
asteroid belt and the in the shape that
Mars is in right now
um and so these um people came from
another planet that was orbiting our sun
they were on a planet named Nibiru
according to the enumi illish and they
came from the bureau
to Earth they went through the hammered
bracelet which is the asteroid belt they
got down to earth and then uh one of
them did and decided wow this is
incredible I finally found the gold that
we need I found the resources that we
need we can create a breakaway
civilization here all the resources are
here to start over again or start a
fresh civilization and so he used this
thing called a crystal tablet which is
crazy to communicate back with his
planet and let them know that he has
found the place to create a new
civilization
and shortly after
this Pantheon they call it a Pantheon so
Pantheon did not originate in Greece and
all that it originated in the ancient
Sumerian Tablets this Pantheon of these
beings came and they started showing up
a little bit at the time and they began
to survey the land and begin to build a
new Breakaway civilization and they
brought these egg with them this is
about 450 000 years ago according to the
tablets
they worked and mined the land and
create structures and cities and
everything else without us we were
already here but we weren't we weren't
working for them we weren't the slaves
yet we were just hunter-gatherers or
whatever we were out here doing our
thing for 200 000 years they put the egg
the egg according to these tabs were the
Working Class People
but they worked for 200 000 years and
they got tired of working according to
the tablet said we they were so pissed
off they were so angry the conditions
were harsh they felt like they were
being converted into slaves and so they
had a coup and they decided to go
against the kings of Earth so there were
a lot of them were working on Mars
and they were building structures and
stuff on this is why there's anomalies
on Mars that match stuff on earth oh
they they went from Mars to Earth to
have a war and these are the sons of God
that fell from heaven
they came down because God who not the
god of the Creator but the god of these
Anunnaki people was Anew the father of
enkian and Lil the uncle of Thoth and
our duck almond raw and they encircled
their camp in uh a place called Adam's
Calendar in South Africa
they found this location this location
is a tourist attraction now it's a very
first gold mine ever discovered they can
date it all the way back to that time
frame
right exactly they needed gold amongst
other things I don't think they were
shipping it back to their home planet
like Zechariah said you were saying
where they were utilizing gold gold is a
technological element you need it for
everything right we couldn't have
anything I couldn't talk to you right
now without this without gold inside
this mic in this computer circuit board
and everything else and so
is the foundation of a high-level
civilization
um and so they decided enki says I have
an idea to stop this war
there's an existing being on this planet
we can add our add our Essence to it and
have it bear the load in other words we
can genetically modify it
make it more uh make it understand what
we're saying make it make it uh you know
make it less volatile or or whatever
domesticate it and then we can make it
do the work that you guys are doing you
guys can take off now and it was agreed
upon in the tablets so they started this
project of capturing hominids and
tinkering with their DNA and they
started off with this cloning system at
first but the problem was they couldn't
make when they were mate they weren't
having babies just like if you made a
tiger and a lion you have a tie gone but
you don't have babies right so they were
like man what are we gonna do here this
is crazy it's too much work to have to
keep making these slaves if we don't
want to go back to war against these
people
so Isis says I have an idea Isis Isis
Isis says she was part of the story yes
she says I'm going to take an egg from
one of the women
and they took the egg and they cleaned
up by the egg that's right
okay sorry keep going that's okay this
is another submarine tablet she took the
egg and she cleaned out some of the
genetic material or whatever they did
they made a zygote they added some of
their Essence to the egg they say
Essence I think that's genetic
modification in my understanding
they took this zygote which is what you
call the modern science they put it in
her womb
she took it to term 10 months not nine
ten months and then you see her in this
famous cylinder scroll holding up this
baby saying my hands have created it she
gave birth to the adamu which means
first man it was not the first human
being that ever existed it's the first
successful homo sapien sapien that now
should be able to reproduce on its own
because Isis supposedly had sex and a
baby from
um putting back together the body of
Osiris right which of course didn't
happen there's obviously symbolic it's
symbolic so yeah that freaking connects
that dot right right exactly what
happened and so they raised Adam and it
was missing his penis right wasn't it I
think Osiris was missing oh Cyrus she
she was missing his penis correct
exactly
yeah and so and they they so they put
Adam in this Eden e-d-i-n and the Lord
of Eden where she was a Satan was the
name the guy who ruled over Eden was
Satan the Lord of Eden in the tablets
okay and that was actually and Lil and
the Bible calls him Yahweh they think
he's God that guy's just masquerading
his guy it was never God
and this Eden was this laboratory where
they would have these mating rituals
between the different peoples and they
got when they got Adam in there they
tried to mate him with these other ones
wasn't working out so they said okay
let's take some DNA from him let's make
another one of him they made Eve then
they made it them and bingo it worked so
they didn't make eight billion people
from two they made more atoms and more
aves and made more atoms and more Eaves
through the general process of you know
getting pregnant and birthing
and so they created this genetic
diversity so they can then create and
multiply who people can't create 8
billion I did the mathematics last night
I actually talked about this on a
podcast last night for for there to be
eight billion people on Earth and the
Earth only be you know according to
Christians six thousand years ago is
when all this started you'd have to have
on the first day they had sex it have to
be 1.3 million people born that day and
every single day thereafter until today
to have eight billion people oh yeah
that just didn't happen didn't happen
and so they created this diversity of
pool of genetics and then they kept
cross mating in a way which is why they
had such strict rules on mating and when
you committing who you can mate with to
prevent inbreeding this was a great
story in these tablets wow and that's
how they began to create the diversity
that puts out the homo sapiens sapien
um crazy story that was about 200 000
years ago they also genetically modified
Us by taking chromosome number two out
of our body fusing it together and
putting telomere caps on each end to
limit our lifespans and scientists now
geneticists universities they teach this
they say we don't know how this happened
it's an artificial mutation that would
have taken millions of years to happen
but it happened about 200 000 years ago
so the tablets line up with modern
science once again
about 120 years right isn't that the cap
isn't that the telomere cap sort of
prediction is that it's you have 120
years to live if you live that's it
that is absolutely right and that's
about all people live too we're making
it to 80 if we're lucky now because all
the toxins and poisons if it wasn't for
that we'd make it to 120. so what's up
with the junk DNA oh yeah so the junk
DNA is not junk it's they call it junk
but it's just disconnected nodes so our
ancestors our cousins who were here
already on this planet in my opinion
after researching them they were more
advancing us not technologically but
spiritually their bones have been left
behind we found the skulls they found
the bones bigger bigger skulls bigger
bones bigger brain capacity not smaller
but larger brain capacity probably had
larger pineal glands they probably had
more DNA connected which gave them the
capability of different uh imbued
sensory perception like telekinesis
maybe or silent Community you know
communication understanding how to sense
the magnetic field of Earth right now we
have billions of magnetite crystals in
our heads and we can't sense the Earth's
magnetic field we can't navigate VIA
magnetism but they could back then
inside of the pineal gland is crystals
it's crystalline crystalline structure
right it's a crystalline structure that
uh when you put the right amount of
pressure it will spark you can have a
Kundalini Awakening you know but a lot
of that has been lost and forgotten
about as we become technological babies
and we rely everything for on everything
external we don't go to our internal
technology to use it anymore can we
activate it
oh yeah you can definitely activate the
um you know the breath the best way to
activate your pineal gland first of all
is to detox it getting away from
fluorides and toxins and processed foods
and and eating clean
um and then of course through meditation
but also through a special type of
meditation called breath work meditation
breath work meditation for two to three
hours will create this scenario in the
brain where the brain thinks you're
getting near death when you do the
breath work technique and then it forces
the pineal gland to to pressure up and
squeeze and release more DMT you could
have a psychedelic experience without
going to the Jungle
yeah and without throwing up or right
purging sorry or somebody robbing you or
abducting you and taking your organs out
you know all kind of crazy stuff happens
when people go to get the these uh these
substances they don't know what they're
getting into what are we as a human body
well the human body is an avatar just
like the movie Avatar it's a receptor
and we receives and holds the spirit
temporarily
and so the Avatar body is set up in a
way where it's it's a biological robot
and machine imbued with sophisticated
Technologies and advanced capabilities
that we are right now are not fully
tapped into some people have better
gifts and energy than others and some
haven't accessed any of it but the way
the body is set up we have a couple
things that hold your spirit in your
body it lock that frequency in one is
the neural correlates of Consciousness
those are three giant neurons that wrap
around the inside of the skull and when
you look at them on a scan it looks like
a crown of thorns oh my God that story
before right so it's a as a metaphor
Jesus with the crown of thorns is
Christ's Consciousness it has nothing to
do with him putting on a real crown of
thorns it's the one that's inside of
every single human being's head right
now
but that works in collaboration with the
magnetite Crystal and your colostrum and
your neocortex those things all work
together to combine to allow a frequency
to be encapsulated and be hosted inside
the physical Avatar body so it's a ghost
you become the Ghost in the Shell and
you animate this shell via that Spirit
that's being housed and it's only being
locked in because of those four things I
just mentioned we have a tremendous
amount of power within us too I've
always been so fascinated with just how
much power the body can produce and
which is like uh how many trillion volts
it's like insane 2.3 2.63 trillion volts
of electricity each cell has .07 volts
of electricity in the human you know
each cell and you add up the amount of
cells it becomes trillions of volts of
electricity I mean it's crazy how much
power we have inside of us and that's
the secret in Reiki and Qigong it's
understanding how have to move the
energy from those cells and channel it
through the body for the purpose of
healing and so forth which is one of the
things that Yeshua AKA Jesus became a
master at did you ever um read the
Magdalene manuscript with uh with um the
story from Mary Magdalene and how they
used sex to
strengthen his car body the etheric
field the second body yeah yeah
would that be part of that
part of strengthening his body
energetically moving and it's pretty
interesting because you talk about
recycling the Kundalini there's special
techniques that even men can do where
you can actually uh not eject you can
act ejaculate but not not release the
semen and in recirculate energy back in
through the Kundalini again is all these
different type of Tantra techniques
um and so according to ancient sages and
wisdom Keepers it's real and it actually
works you know it's a technique that can
be learned and actually perfected that's
pretty interesting stuff wow so then
what's the role of the brain the brain
is just a like a microchip you know it's
a microprocessor it's a you know it's a
central processing unit it allows you to
be able to to connect to multiple
dimensions and so if you look back to
some of my oldest videos maybe eight ten
years ago I was talking about the fact
that the Universe has 11 dimensions and
the Brain can tap into all those higher
dimensions
and people used to laugh at me tell me I
was crazy and you're making all this
stuff up just last year in 2022
scientists at the brain Institute
discovered that the brain now connects
to 11 dimensions and that the Universe
where I got the concept of 11 dimensions
of the universe first was from
theoretical physicists like Michio Kaku
saying that the universe is 11
dimensions are over collapse when I
looked into it many other people
collaborated it became peer-reviewed
science so then I hypothesized that the
brain is connecting to those 11 as well
because we are multi-dimensional beings
and those are the dimensions we're
connecting with on a moment by moment
basis and we have the capability of
tapping into higher knowledge and higher
dimensions and then to uh 2022 it
finally comes out they discovered it's
actually real and that the brain is is a
multi-dimensional functional computer as
a processor it allows us to tap in and
inhabit and incorporate spiritual energy
and also what we call physical third
dimensional
um you know uh feelings and energy so it
combines the spiritual and the physical
together in one place how can we in
have more awareness for those dimensions
the best thing to do is get into what I
call The merkaba Meditation
merka ba I had three words actually
sounds like one
but it's an ancient meditation technique
to actually teach this and I do a guided
meditation on my TV network
it you you actually end up going through
this meditation where you step into your
vehicle of Ascension which is what the
merkaba is is this star tetrahedron
that's counterclockwise spinning and you
actually can get inside of it and take
it to higher Dimensions you can travel
to Dimensions through the merkaba it's
even talked about in the animal tablets
both talks about traveling to these
higher Dimensions as well via the same
exact technique could this be also then
used as time travel
because when I think about time travel I
think we think we want to take our body
and go somewhere else but look like
I feel like I you I'm travel at night
when you go to sleep you time travel
when you do certain you know modalities
and techniques like breathing or EMDR or
something like that you can revisit the
past and so like in your opinion what is
what would time travel actually look
like and are we actually already doing
it there's a couple ways to do it if you
want to look at the non-physical
movement of it it can be done through
the mind we know that through remote
viewing through other mind techniques
and thought experiments that the the
mind can travel backwards and forwards
in time to collect information the mind
can even be sent to different locations
to connect collect data an Intel which
the US military actually had a problem
the CIA had a military program for it's
called project Stargate for that one
purpose sending Minds outside of space
and time to gather Intel against foreign
enemy and stuff like that so we know
that's a real program that actually
existed and it's 100 possible the other
way is through these different types of
meditations you can create the same
situation or scenario with those talks
about utilizing it to go through these
gates the gates of Heaven he says the
Gates of Heaven is not what people think
it's these Stargates that take you to
other dimensions and locations and at
these higher Dimensions the past present
and future exist at the same time
it would be like me looking down at
myself from a higher Dimension that
would be like looking at myself in a
house in the house I'm in now from a
higher Dimension I can see myself in
every single room in this house but at a
different stage in my life and I'm
witnessing it all at once
okay so that's another form of time
travel and then in the physical way we
time travel all the time if you hop on a
plane if you get into a rocket and go
into space if you drive a race car
anyone that's moving away at a specific
speed relative to somebody standing
still is moving forward uh you're moving
forward in time just ever so slightly
tiny tiny plonk units of a moment but
they're measurable yeah measurable going
backwards in time is also possible but
that wouldn't require the capability of
moving percentages higher percentages of
the speed of light because that would
then allow you to go backward in time
the problem of going back with the time
you have the grandfather Paradox and so
if I go go back and kill my grandfather
how was I born to go back in time I
solved that Paradox by saying and
hypothesizing that if I travel back in
time the reason why I can kill my
grandfather and still have gone back to
do it is because I'm now on an
alternative timeline sure I don't think
you can go back in time on the same
timeline you shift into an alternate
universe if you go forward you can stay
on your same timeline if you go backward
you shift into an alternate timeline
that's my personal hypothesis I love to
go into the thought around quantum
entanglement and how it's
possible
to affect
an atom at one side of the universe to
the other instantaneously the quantum
entanglement it's a it's amazing quantum
entanglement first came to me when I was
just doing a walking meditation it came
to me as parabolic down conversion and
so I go and look it up a lot of my
information comes to me like getting
that I go research it and find out it's
actually real yeah it's the craziest
thing it's coming from the field you're
getting it from the field and then you I
find that with so many brilliant people
that are doing this total esoteric
knowledge research is that you actually
back into it you're like you have an
epiphany you think something and then
you figure it out so exactly it's
exactly how it happened so I'm like
parabolic down conversion so I go look
it up it's the method used to take two
particles and phase shift them on the
same frequency so that you can Quantum
entangle the particles then you could
take one particle and shift it to the
other end of the universe if you can get
there and when you change the particle
local to you the other one will change
instantaneously in other words if one is
in a spin rate up the other one was
supposed spin right down when you twist
this one is put it down this one will go
up and vice versa so you can create this
up down communication between two
entangled particles
it goes even further than that
scientists now discovered that you can
Quantum entangle through conscious
thought and they've actually entangled
people's thoughts together now it took
one person and put them in front of a
video game screen put another person
that was thinking two Laboratories away
he had the remote control the guy in
front of the screen was blindfolded the
guy who was two Laboratories away was
looking at the screen but the one that
was blindfolded had the remote control I
mean so the one that was looking was
controlling the hand of the one that was
blindfolded could play the game
so they entangled two minds already real
science so we know that when we get an
epiphany like that there's very rarely a
original thought a lot of the times we
get in sync with a thought that already
exists because we know that all thoughts
are light waves so every single thought
you're thinking right now and I'm
thinking right now it generates waves
that leave our skull and go out into the
ether permanently
forever and so that's why the akashic
records is real that's why the book of
life is real because everyone's
conscious thoughts are all around us
floating around in this ether we call
the grid and it's all this every
everything everywhere is all connected
and so you can get in sync with
something and you can download it and if
you can discern that download you can
have an epiphany moment and so quantum
entanglement is so incredible because if
you really understand where we're gonna
go in the future with Communications
it's going to be Quantum entangled
Communications
so right now if you travel from Earth to
the rings of Saturn on a vacation it
takes you three months to get you know
send a message back and get the message
you know get the message to Earth and
get the message back to the spaceship so
if there's a problem you really got a
real problem because nobody's coming to
help you but if you have a Quantum
entangle Communications device on Earth
and you take one with you in the ship or
you have a communications array that's
been launched years ahead into deep
space you can communicate what you can
communicate with the array or your
Quantum entangle communication device
you can instantaneously send a response
and get a response back
and so that's where the future is going
to go with this quantum entanglement but
as far as humans go understanding that
all thoughts and ideas and Concepts most
likely are downloaded from the field
very few original thoughts I think that
almost everything that can be thought of
has already been thought and exist in
this soup you know just like an alien
race of two light years away can pick up
I Love Lucy from 1960 because that radio
wave which is a wave of light
can be picked up and decoded and you can
watch I Love Lucy from 1960. so what's
the mechanism that connects it though
and this is where I get a little spun
out and I've heard from a physicist that
inside of each and every one of us is a
black hole and then I start to think
that maybe we're this
it's it gives me like this Pathway to a
loop
where everything you are the universe
like you hold all the frequencies and
patterns so there's just this sort of
like infinite looping that's happening
within you but also in the universe
because it's one in the same through
possibly like black holes or something
is that even it's through fractals right
right we're a Frac we're a fractal of
the whole
and in a fractal if you look at a
hologram if you go to the smallest piece
of a hologram you'll find the whole
image in the smallest piece the only
thing you lose is resolution and we're
living in a fractal holographic matrix
that's what we're actually living in and
this whole thing is one giant energetic
grid
and the thing about it is distance is an
illusion the distance between where I am
now in Florida and wherever you are
right now in the world is actually it
doesn't even exist we're still all we're
local in the same location we're still
connected in the same location
individuality separation all Illusions
doesn't exist there's only one entity in
one consciousness
providing this third dimension with the
illusion of separation and quantum
entanglement uh and the way that an
avatar body is set up like from thoughts
for example if you look at our uh our
mind and you then you also look at
Einstein's theory of relativity if you
take a planet
in space it warps space around it and
that warp space allows things to fall
toward the planet that's the Warped
gravity right effect our conscious
thoughts Warp The Ether of space-time
and create this well and that's how the
Law of Attraction When Things Fall
toward us based on what we're warping
what we're focusing on the energy field
that we're using to Warp that's what
begins to fall towards us your thought
is what is being warped towards it which
is why you have to be careful what you
think of exactly exactly so we're
creating our own gravity Wells and we
have our we're creating this situation
where
um you know we are entangling with
information based on frequencies and
wherever that and whatever that
frequency we're on when we're thinking
that's the warp space that's now sending
back low frequency things or if it's
you're in high frequency warp space is
sending back high frequency things
you're entanging with things in the
universe based on the frequency you're
at so one of my greatest questions is
well these are such deep rabbit holes
and someone like my dad would be like
why are you looking into stuff that you
can't Brew I'm like well you gotta ask
the question if we can get closer to the
answer then I feel like I'll know how to
live this life better I'll know how to
play this game better so what does all
that teach us about how to best play
this game of life and
be as happy and joyful as possible yeah
great question because that's really
what's on everybody's Minds like how do
I play in The Matrix here like what am I
supposed to do
and when I began to realize that I was
on a data collection Mission and my
mission was to not only collect the
information but figure out a way that
I'm supposed to bring Heaven to Earth
I'm not supposed to wait to die so that
I can live I'm supposed to live now in
this realm and then when I when my
corporeal body releases my spirit energy
I'm going to live again and again and
every Ascension process my mission is to
achieve the highest most best lifestyle
living entity energy help love
Expressions uh artistic creation that I
possibly can in every single Dimension
and I think that for me that's the
understanding I got and so when I when I
figured that out when I had that
Epiphany I said wow my job here is to
how many people can I help how can I
assist others how can I learn how to
walk in the buttons how can I be true to
myself how can I be to be the best that
I can be and also how can I stop and
smell the roses and be blessed and enjoy
my blessings and thank me thank you for
every single thing that I get my hands
on everything that comes to me how can I
truly be heartfully grateful for it I
learned my lessons when something
happens and goes wrong or I make a
mistake do I continue to make that same
mistake or do I learn from that and
become better and better and better and
and that begins us to process in a
step-by-step process for Ascension and
that will ride me out of this realm and
I just out of this Dimension into the
next one so I can continue to build on
that and become better and better and
better so it's to progress through the
dimensions
yeah see the third dimension is a
Proving Ground it's a testing ground
it's an area a place for you to come
uh as an inexperienced soul and begin to
learn and make mistakes and grow and see
what you can do and also a certain level
of suffering and then when you begin to
master this Dimension I think that
people who don't Master keep coming back
over and over and over again I think you
can get to a point according to thoughth
and animal tablets that you actually can
then begin to Incarnate at will he says
where you can you can incarnate on and
in the plane that you desire so plain
means dimension
so he's saying that you can get so good
at this game that you can actually come
back in any Dimension you want or any
location you want any time frame you
want past or present or future let's
talk about like perhaps the more
nefarious evil forces here that hold us
back from that reality yeah
um what would they be both calls them
the dark brothers and The Emerald
Tablets he says the dark brothers and
behold of the dark Brothers they they're
behind the scenes fooling all the
strings controlling the world
controlling the people from behind the
scenes into darkness which is exactly
what we have we have 100 families
operating behind the scenes controlling
8 billion people and what he warns is
that it's really our fault that this
happens and this has happened he's
absolutely right if you understand
what's going on on this planet and the
control and the book that's on our neck
right now we have been in complete
collusion with that happening to us we
have allowed it to happen because
there's no way people we participate
participation is our collusion that's
our approval to continue to accept
what's being done to us and what they've
done is something brilliant divide and
conquer they've got us divided which has
conquered us they've got the political
system left wing right wing you got the
races black white red yellow green blue
whatever you got all these things you
got the different kind of churches your
Protestant the Catholic no I'm Baptist
all this is separation right and so with
the separation tactics what's happened
is we can't see the smoke that they're
blowing up our butt we have to realize
look we got to come together we need to
organize we need to stop playing this
game there's only one way to stop this
cabal from operating on this planet and
that's for all of us to come together
and do one thing just stop playing the
game when we when we do that we will
then create a new economic system we'll
create a new structure uh for leadership
in this country or all the world
actually and we could release suppressed
Technologies and create an abundant
civilization on this planet because
there's more more than enough for 20
billion people to live here and Thrive
we have eight billion people here but 90
of those people are suffering so we can
create a civilization that would be like
an oasis in the middle of the Milky Way
galaxy but it's up to us to learn and
develop uh and work past this Divine and
Conquer stuff and understand that we're
all brothers and sisters and we're
supposed to work together and love one
another and help one another and not
allow these globally leaders to destroy
us and pin us against each other when
there's a war being called they're never
on the front line it's always us
you know if we if you want to go to war
then there should be a law any any
politician or ruler that calls the law a
war yeah they should be the first one
then when their famous go first you go
you guys go first and then let us know
what happens when the front lines down
then we'll come out next they'll never
be a war again
so is it extraterrestrials is it I mean
there's always the talk about reptilians
is there extraterrestrial just are they
working through our Consciousness
um I mean shoot I even heard an old
story a story from uh someone I
interviewed Elizabeth April saying that
the Anunnaki and the reptilians were
here and that the Galactic Federation
said
you guys gotta go and the Anunnaki were
like peace see ya and this was in Egypt
um and the reptilians were like no no we
don't want to leave and they're like
fine but you can't be seen by the you
can't be seen by the humans and so they
went underground and then they started
going through our Consciousness to
control us and that they essentially
still run the world but we just don't
see them some of it comes out of the
nakamadi scripts so they believed in
this reptilian type of a race that was
in this phase shifted reality that can
actually
um dominate Mankind from this behind the
veil type mechanism
they also have another one that kind of
looks like an embryonic a person but
it's embryonic looks like a gray alien
kind of weird stuff in these nag hamadi
Scripts and it talks about these kind of
beings there's also been Crypts in
places underground even in the Americas
where they found remnants of what seemed
to be this ancient reptilian race and of
course you know in Samaria they found
the ubaid culture with thousands of
statues of these reptilian people so
there could be some truth to that there
could be some actual truth to that in
terms of who's running the world right
now I believe there's still people who
are in direct Bloodline with the
Sumerian Kings list the Sumerian Kings
list which is located at the ashmolean
Museum in Oxford England has a list of
kings that rule for hundreds of
thousands of years and these Kings were
not humans they were these Annunaki
people some rule for 14 400 one rule for
28 000 another one rule for 7 800 a year
and these ruling periods are like
mind-blowing time frame I had to go
there in person to witness it and look
at it with my own eyes which I did
and um there are people who believe
they're they're the direct descendants
of these beings and that they have the
right to rule over human beings still to
this very day and so I think a lot of
those are these families behind the
scenes that are ruling they could have
more of a direct bloodline to these
alien people how do we overcome that
other than what's what's the steps I
understand that we can't participate
anymore but what are the steps like what
would what would we do next
well the steps are what you're doing a
podcast like this the work that I do and
many others around the world that are
trying to help awaken Mankind from
various different aspects podcasts TV
shows Productions you know internet
influencers books you know and
everything else we got going on it's all
this edutainment that we're putting out
to try to Enlighten and awaken people to
find out who they truly are first so
once you find out who you are then you
can begin to reach out and realize wow
everyone is me I gotta help as many
people as I can that's the processes
we're just in the beginning process of
the global Mass Awakening right and
eventually we will come to a point where
people will realize who we truly are and
what we're supposed to do here and we
will take back control of this planet
because no Empire can persist forever
I've never seen I've read over a
thousand books scripture cylinder
Scrolls Papyrus is I've been all around
the world to all kind of indigenous
ancient cultures nowhere has it ever
been written that uh once one Empire is
going to rule for all eternity not one
place
and so I think that we're in a situation
where there's this cycle with circular
service civilizations that rise and fall
of civilizations and that at some point
we will rise back into a golden age and
Take Back Control of this planet we're
in the process of it right now
what was the last golden age
the last golden age was approximately 27
000 years ago
isn't that a isn't there a cycle about a
26 000 year cycle or something like that
yes the Yuga the Kali Yuga cycle now
there are many Golden Ages in between
but it's not Global like each of us had
a couple of Golden Ages within the past
10 000 years but it's just an isolated
area and so but a global a pure Global
wide uh Golden Age every 26 to 27 000
Years you'll see this cycle of rise and
fall right now I think we're in the
Tetra Yuga so if you're going around the
Yugo cycle the this side the side on the
right is like the you know going back
into the bronze and starting all over
again I think we're beyond that we're in
the side over here in this lower left
corner Rising back up towards a golden
age we're in the beginnings of the Tetra
yoga as we're heading into the age of
Aquarius
do just humans keep coming back over and
over again and there's extinctions that
happen and we start over and we just
have to kind of rebuild is that
essentially what happens and in your
research is there a certain point in
which that happens is it always
following the golden age is it when does
that happen within this
very pattern oriented fractal nature of
this reality
right there's a lot of collapses that
have happened via geological disasters
you know it's a part of another cycle
that we're in as well
there's a couple of them one would be
forget asteroids and commas let's talk
about the planet itself we know that the
planet goes through these these pole
shifts right and we're overdue for
another pole shift right now
the pole shift of the crust of the Earth
itself so the crust the physical crust
they're all together on these tectonic
plate lines and sometimes they slip and
when they slip a huge man last can shift
hundreds of degrees in like you know
just minutes which can create a global
flood if you look at Antarctica the
reason why the Antarctica uh you know
the animals are that are discovered
there now have undigested food in their
belly the reason why that is is because
Antarctica used to be closer to the
Equator and because of a pole shift it
moved there very rapidly allowing those
animals to flash freeze because the
water can't cold water came over them
with the cold air everything else they
flash froze with undigested food in
their stomach which is now being
discovered today so we know that was a
pole shift that happened that moved
Antarctica into the position that it's
in now so we have those pole shifts we
also have something else called a
magnetic pole shift
we know that by going to volcanic areas
and taking the volcanic rock and putting
a compass next to it we can see in some
cases going back 26 27 000 years that
the magnetic field has flipped on Earth
so South is North and North is south and
we're in the process of flipping right
now magnetic north is not true north
anymore it's moved over Russia it's
actually passing Russia now which means
that all the airliners all the airports
around the world have changed some of
the landing uh the degrees for the
landing coordinates so that airplanes
can land because it's all based on
coordinates and and magnetic north so
they've had to actually change
accordance to The Landing strips because
of this and we're in the middle of a
flip soon North will be South and South
will be North magnetically which is
going to create what are the
implications of that
well we're talking about chaos if it's
not if we're not prepared for it if it
just happens really quickly you know if
you have GPS errors planes that can
crash satellites can come back to earth
and crash uh you know they'll lose their
orbits um anything that relies on
um GPS Technologies and things like that
are going to have a major major problem
everything will need a software update
everything will need to be reconfigured
yeah so that's another you know
potential protection for that can happen
and then of course you have things like
comments and asteroids
we have a couple of really big ones to
think about I don't want to say worry
because I'm not a I'm not a doomsday
person but Apophis slipped by Earth and
the moon about I don't know if it was
seven eight years ago or whatever it was
it was it slipped through a
gravitational Keyhole now an orbital
mechanics that's not good this thing is
about the size of Texas the next time it
comes around in 20 30 something there's
a potential not definite but there's a
potential it could scrape our atmosphere
or hit the earth which is why Obama
ordered this special mission to land on
a comet and learn how to shift its orbit
because you can't blow them up because
then you have a lot of debris coming in
at once and destroying everything
it's like the movies you need to figure
out how to divert how to like shift it
just a couple degrees to like get it off
that's all you got to do so we have that
so there's all these different things
that happen on these specific Cycles you
know that we're concerned about there's
another one coming February 14th
Valentine's Day again another 20 30 or
20 40 something
it slipped through a gravitational
Keyhole and it could be an impact with
Earth as well it's a little bit smaller
but still deadly so we have these things
that are out there that you know we're
in this Goldilocks time frame of mankind
right now where we were allowed to grow
to this just this uh this level of
technology and the only thing that will
save us is can we technologically
continue to advance to the point where
we can save ourselves from these type of
disasters
um what about getting off planet do you
think that's important
I think it's majorly important to get
off planet and create Breakaway
civilizations that that's what the
Anunnaki did they came to Earth as a
breakaway civilization and they went to
Mars as well and I think in order to uh
ensure our longevity as a species in the
universe we need to get off this planet
and create Breakaway civilizations in
other places I think I think it's
important extremely important
uh isn't Nibiru on a 3600 year cycle of
coming into our orbit or orbiting near
us
yeah so it's shifted orbit over time so
in the beginning stages according to the
enumelicia it was a Shah 3 600 years now
they've rediscovered this object which
they say is about four to six times
larger than Earth it is very strange
elliptical orbit around our sun and it
has a brown dwarf star with it so it's
orbiting a brown dwarf star and this
brown dwarf is orbiting our Sun every 4
200 years now so it's shifted over time
it's moving just like our moon is moving
back a few centimeters every single year
in about you know in a hundred thousand
years it'll be a tiny dot in the sky
same thing is happening with this uh
brown dwarf in the bureau so do is it
your understanding that Nibiru coming
into our orbit on its cycle has been
part of our evolutionary upgrades it's
been part of it's been part of
geological disasters not the upgrades
the upgrades came from
um the Annunaki coming here and
tinkering with our DNA but the biggest
part of our genetic upgrades and our DNA
upgrade has been the fact that our solar
system undulates up and down like this
as it goes around the Milky Way galaxy
so this undulation represents hundreds
of thousands of my 100 hundreds of
millions of miles up and down right now
we are at the galactic equator line so
we're direct Center to the supermassive
black hole at the center of our our
galaxy The Milky Way galaxy there are
super high charge streaming particles
coming straight out of this
right from the Milky Way uh center from
the Black from the black hole right
towards us and penetrating us and
altering and changing our DNA these
supercharged energetic particles are in
my opinion changing us upgrading us
helping us to awaken ourselves as well
does this affect the Schumann residence
on the planet is that what that is yes
it affects the human residence on the
planet and the frequency of the planet
itself I'm 40 years old like you know In
Our Lifetime are we gonna see a drastic
difference or how long do you think it's
going to take to really truly
evolve
D you know the evolution of our
Consciousness happens very fast although
because our lifespans are short it seems
like it's taking forever so you look at
um 100 years ago we were in a horse
buggy and carriage
and now now we can put a remote control
car on on a planet like Mars right and
look and look around Mars we've come a
very very long way in a short period of
time I think consciously we have the
capability of seeing some significant
change in our lifetime so you know I'm
52. I'll be 52 in September
and so I think before I leave this earth
as long as nothing crazy happens to me I
get a chance to witness some of the most
miraculous and most incredible changes
in the way that we think and perceive
ourselves and the world and how we begin
to change this planet I think I'll be in
the very beginning stages at least get
to witness some of that before I leave
and so it's this process where you know
it happens over time it could be another
three four thousand years to see the
world we truly want to see but we'll get
glimpses of it and like I say
mankind is like a baby learning how to
walk so right now we're crawling and
we're trying to grab onto the edge of
the couch or a little table and pull
ourselves up and so we're getting this
excitement with this Global Awakening
that's happening it's the baby trying to
stand up eventually that baby will take
a step but then the baby will fall and
it looked like it all came crashing to
an end again people will get depressed
and angry and frustrated but it's just
the process of learning how to walk
eventually that baby grabs on and it
cries but it grabs on and pulls up and
takes two steps false three four five
steps false eventually the baby learns
how to walk and that's where we have to
get to that's why it's going to take so
much more time walking is a series of
controlled Falls that's the actual
definition and we have to get to that
point where we're controlling our fault
oh wow all right if there was like one
one tangible takeaway that everyone
could
to grab onto and keep in mind what would
that be to help our Ascension and to
help our evolution
I think the biggest thing I can tell
people is to look into their own selves
self-help self work Shadow work you know
biohacking meditation you know eating
clean exercise uh and then also
operating in service to others
unconditional love for others
when somebody gets you angry or
frustrated that's a mental test
can you withdraw those emotions can you
feel them but it work through them and
then say you know what that person did
something to me but I blessed this
person because we have the power to
bless people somebody cuts you off in
traffic don't get angry and flip them
off run up in your mind and say wait a
minute stop I bless this person I hope
they make it to their destination safely
these are the type of mental spiritual
tests we need to be putting ourselves
through on a daily basis to get get
ourselves to ascend to the higher level
it's like lifting weights and you become
stronger and stronger and then you
become incredible you become an
incredible being of light that way well
thank you I have a lot of work to do on
the road not getting mad at people it's
a very common source of frustration for
me but I will work on that that is my
test
um one of many
um thank you Billy amazing like blow
your mind stuff and I'm sure everybody
else is thinking the same thing so keep
doing the good work and um I'll be
watching thank you so much I appreciate
you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button